so you grew up in the u.s your whole
life
exactly when did you come to japan for
the first time um
i i've been coming back to japan um like
pretty much
every year when i was little parents
just to go to
my um grandparents house and stuff and
then i went to
uh i came to japan in middle school
and i experienced japanese school
education for the first time in my life
how was that going from americans
um it was completely hope for me because
um even though i can speak
regular sort of everyday japanese i
can't
read or write um up to par
am i allowed to ask this but why were
you going to school in japan like what
was there
that's the music thing okay oh okay
oh musician in japan so i came to japan
to do music
and i still had to go to school so i
went to school but i went to regular
school which was a huge mistake and i
didn't go to international school or you
know that kind of thing
so how was that why why was it a mistake
um it's just that i couldn't keep up
with any of the education
and i was a complete loner so i didn't
have any friends
i was gonna ask is it hard to make
friends when you're like a transfer
student i think it's impossible to make
friends
that's such a lot of i would have you
believe that the transfer student
everyone wants everyone wants to know
the transfer student why would you lie
to me anime
i think there's like there's that one
scene where it's like a transfer student
from overseas
who's like oh they can speak english and
then during the break
they're [ __ ] all over that transfer
student right like did that happen to
you at all
um big surprise here and i and i'm gonna
give you a
huge uh sort of reality check but as an
anime singer
um anime is not exactly real
[Laughter]
no i respect your opinion i do
but i'm gonna live in my reality
i will choose to break break it to you
guys but no
no but i mean you didn't sit in like the
far corner of the
classroom next to the window i was
actually you know since i came to japan
and then i
started um the school at a very
weird time in the sort of year right
that was like in the corner
and so i couldn't make friends and i
couldn't keep up with the studies and
i everything like the culture was
completely right
yeah it's quite different for america
yeah i guess for you as well it's like
doubly a pressure right because you're
full japanese everyone expects me to
be japanese right you know if i looked
sort of american probably people would
be like you know nihongo daijo
but no people would be like completely
normal you know
they expect me to understand completely
everything so that was
huge sort of stress for me mentally did
you
how good was your japanese when you
moved here um
i could speak it but reading and writing
was
completely so japanese is technically
your second language yes it's
technically my second language and i
didn't like
actually officially study japanese in
america right okay so
and so you were in japanese school until
high school then like
just for less than two years i think
because you were like thank god
i gave up and then i went back to the
states and then i
finished school there and then after i
finished school i came to japan and
started my career so okay what is the
japanese education system like compared
to
the us because i i've thought about like
you know if because i was also you know
i was raised in the uk that was where my
education system is
i can't imagine having an education in
asia because that
the culture of the asian education
system just seems like
a lot of pressure yeah and that's
something that i'm not a fan of at all
um i think you know in japan um
i'd i've only been as a student for two
less than two years i can't say i know
everything but at the same time i think
they're very like
like studying based like everything is
about studying studying studying and
it's very difficult
um to be a loner in school
in japan like it's you have to have your
sort of
niche and you have to have your place
and you have to friends in order to
really
um feel like so
sure who are like the cool kids in
japanese schools who are like the
popular kids because
in like when i was growing up it would
be like the people who are good at
sports or like the jocks
and stuff like that who is like who are
like the prop what makes you popular
in japanese schools i've always wondered
about i think it is different in japan
like um
it doesn't necessarily mean like uh you
have to be like the most fashionable or
anything but
in japan it's more if you're outgoing
and you're also smart
right educationally yeah that's what i
think anime got right yeah
i noticed there's a big difference
because when i was growing up in the uk
if you did will and test that's like uh
that's like that's like a black market
like whoa you studied for an exam
look at this [ __ ] nerd whereas in
japan it's like whoa you study oh my god
you're awesome
you know that kind of thing is different
yeah um like if you're an all-rounder if
you're good at a lot of different things
then
you're pretty much you know the image of
perfection yeah
you're just gonna ever just go to
everything japan loves perfection
yeah yeah i think they sort of exert
perfection
in the enemy as well like the animes uh
they
sort of um depict perfection in
animation
yeah yeah i don't know if you don't have
to answer this question if you don't
want to
but did you ever have like any negative
experiences like bullying because you
were
like foreign or um there wasn't exactly
like
direct bullying but people didn't know
how to interact with me because they
because it wasn't international school
and they weren't exposed to foreign
people they at the time though now of
course there are a lot of foreigners in
japan but at the time there were
like if there was a foreigner walking
around in shibuya people would be like
yeah yeah i mean it's still like that in
some cases
didn't have an immune system for like
english and foreign and so
um you know just the fact that i came
from the us
and that i was an outsider people were
like i don't know how to interact with
them
do they know the same language they
didn't really know how to interact with
me
so uh even though i was really outgoing
in a lot i'm gonna people love her
yeah um no no one really wanted to you
know sort of interact
with me like directly yeah they were
very shy yeah
is very shy so yeah um that was one of
the biggest
stresses yeah i definitely noticed that
especially recently i feel
even just like looking like you know
going out into the town and stuff like
that you do
see like yeah because like when we were
in school like i never went to a
japanese school either because i just
didn't really want to i heard terrible
things about it um
but you know back then it was like yeah
if you're if you look
any different at all because it's such a
collectivist society you're just not
gonna fit in like no matter
how hard you trust i'm like i'm not even
gonna bother with that [ __ ] but like
nowadays like you know the other day i
saw like
a bunch of high school girls in uniform
and
among like the three or four japanese
girls there was like one girl who was
just like clearly
like african-american like black yeah so
it's like full-on and i was and they
were like just
hanging out with her like it was nothing
i'm in my head i was just like
hell yeah finally like kids
actually like are starting to understand
in japan i'm like you guys took your
[ __ ] time
yeah so if i came to japan now as a
teenager
and went to school i'd probably have a
much better time yeah
experience yeah definitely you know yeah
because i feel like it's extra pressure
as well because i
i i kind of relate to that where like i
feel like if you're like
american or something or you know
something that you know your
your blood isn't from japan um it would
be a lot more exotic
but because you're 100 japanese
coming back to japan you feel like a
foreigner in your own home sometimes
because i felt like i felt like that
when i went back to thailand
right because you know every people like
foreigners in thailand
but for me i'm i feel like i'm a
foreigner in thailand but it's kind of
like a disappointment because
i'm 100 thai but so they expect me to be
fully tired fully fluent and fully
understanding of the culture and
everything but
and when they see that i'm not they're
just like ah okay
so you're not one of us but you're also
not cool for being a foreigner either
like
because i grew up in america but i i
lived on the west coast
um for most of my life and so there were
very few asian people and at the time
though um the japanese boom wasn't
yeah existent yet yeah so no one really
liked japan yet
everyone was like the asian people were
all one category
yeah yeah you're chinese you're japanese
you're the same thing yeah
and so i felt very like uh
sort of you know left out in the
community i didn't know my identity
there
and so then i came to japan and then i
experienced the same thing where i
didn't have an identity
i wasn't completely japanese i wasn't
completely american
we're still not um used to having you
know foreign people
in japan yet and so my timing is just
completely off my entire life